that perseverance is really well named
it takes a lot of perseverance to stay
in science science is hard and um and
that's why it's so great that the space
mission can
um you know the the um uh the space
program can encourage students to stick
with it because we we need these
students to um to to stay in science and
and Engineering to help you know solve
the the problem the problem in the
future so I encourage students to
persevere science science is hard it's
hard for everybody and so if a student
is feeling like it's hard for them it's
it's um uh uh it's hard for everybody so
so don't be discouraged persevere in
science and um and help solve the the
problems
um and um and work on the exciting you
know interesting problems of tomorrow
um yes well I'm a professor of
geoscience
um at UNLV and I study a water Rock
interactions and so what happens when
minerals and liquid water uh interact
and um we use a variety of uh laboratory
experiments modeling and field
experiments to understand that and we're
particularly interested in what those
results can tell us about both Earth and
Mars and we also look at the impact of
microorganisms on those types of
reactions
students have an opportunity UNLV
students have an opportunity to
participate in the missions and when the
samples come back they'll be available
to people who are students now to work
on
and I would say the the biggest benefit
um from the space program is that it uh
uh inspires students
um to to go into science
um I think that the the excitement of
the space program can help you know
students stay engaged in science and
even if not all of them you know become
planetary scientists maybe they become
engineers and maybe they become doctors
and or maybe they go into biomedicine
and they help to uh to work on um you
know solving problems
um you know problems in our society and
so yes the the space program has a lot
of benefits to um to us here on Earth